[Musica]
tu parli veneziano e anche tu parli
veneziano
la verità è che tutti voi parlate
veneziano e non dico chi tra voi sia
nato o viva a venezia
intendo proprio tutti tutti scrivete
anche in veneziano è che non lo sapete
questo perché venezia ha finito col
diventare nel corso della storia
una città ponte ponte fra culture fra
persone fra saperi gb e consuetudini al
punto che alcune tra queste consuetudini
sono divenute patrimonio del mondo
intero sono divenute internazionali
ogni giorno voi utilizzate qualcosa che
è stato inventato a venezia oggetti ma
non solo anche nell'esprimersi nel
mandare un messaggio su whatsapp nello
scrivere un post su instagram voi
utilizzate qualcosa che è nato a venezia
ve ne faccio vedere un'immagine eccola
riuscite a vederlo no e perché a
grandezza naturale
ora ve lo ripropongo ingrandito un
milione di volte l'avete riconosciuto
adesso ve lo è il punto
il punto e con lui la virgola l'accento
l'apostrofo il punto e virgola
così come sono in uso nella forma
moderna sono stati utilizzati per la
prima volta a venezia dove non si
inventa la stampa ma si perfeziona la
punteggiatura che aiuta a scrivere ea
leggere meglio
d'altronde ponte significa anche
prendere e trasformare ricreare e
proporre esportare a venezia dove nel
corso del cinquecento si pubblica almeno
la metà dei libri stampati in tutta
europa in quell intero secolo viene
inventato il corsivo che non a caso si
chiama italic in tutti i computer nel
mondo
viene messo a punto il libro tascabile
che diventa da quel momento un oggetto
trasportabile tutto ciò si deve al genio
di aldo manuzio che non era veneziano ma
che a venezia ebbe modo di sperimentare
e affermare le sue intuizioni perché
venezia fu così ebbe la capacità di
attrarre ri mescolare e fondere e far
diventare veneziana qualsiasi cosa
potenzialmente innovativa potesse
accrescere le fortune dello stato non
esiste una sola pietra della città che
non sia arrivata da un altrove è stato
valido anche per le persone nel corso
della storia in gran parte di questa
capacità di prendere il meglio e di
farlo diventare il veneziano
abbiamo un meraviglioso esempio in un
documento che per la prima volta nella
storia parla esplicitamente di
protezione delle idee vi sono molti
uomini si legge dal testo originale di
diverse origini uomini commenti
ingegnose in grado di immaginare
immaginare diversi oggetti artificiosi e
se si facesse sì che altri non possano
riprodurre le opere da essi inventate
allora questi uomini userebbero le loro
menti per scoprire cose di non poca
utilità per la nostra repubblica
venezia inventa il brevetto lo fa il 19
marzo 1474 ma torniamo alle parole
quante volte nei giorni più cupi del
covip 19
abbiamo pronunciato ho sentito
pronunciare le parole quarantena o
lazzaretto lazzaretto è invenzione e
parola veneziana deriva dalla corruzione
di nazareth um
ovvero la chiesa di santa maria di
nazareth che sorgeva sulla prima isola
della laguna deputata a questo scopo nel
1423 il lazzaretto vecchio qualche tempo
dopo fu istituito al lazzaretto nuovo
con scopi di prevenzione verso merci e
persone che venivano tenuti in
isolamento per 40 giorni
la quarantenne
inventata a ragusa dopo che per secoli
era stata possedimento veneziano è che i
veneziani perfezionarono non è
nient'altro che quarantina in veneziano
quando dite quarantena o lazzaretto
parlate veneziano senza saperlo anche la
parola detto nasce a venezia assieme al
primo tetto della storia istituito nel
1516 per dare ospitalità agli ebrei in
città non era un villaggio vacanze e le
restrizioni erano significative ma non
era nemmeno un luogo di persecuzione o
di tortura e la parola ha detto che
viene accolta da molte lingue del mondo
e che è associato a giustamente ai
concetti di separazione sofferenza
enqelab nasce in realtà innocentissima
perché ne precede l'esistenza stessa in
quel luogo vi erano delle antiche
fonderie il getto che gli avevano dato
il nome e che i primi ebrei askenaziti
nord europei trasformarono come una
pronuncia più dura quando di the ghetto
parlate veneziano e forse non lo sapete
lo fate anche quando dite arsenale
quello di venezia fu la prima vera
catena di montaggio della storia capace
di varare navi a una velocità
impressionante
al punto da entrare nel lessico comune
di molte lingue gli anglofoni sembrano
anzi essere fra i più fedeli
riproduttori di parole veneziane ma non
solo di quelle anche di altre cose come
l'architettura di andrea palladio per
esempio venezia peraltro inventa e
andrea palladio n'è uno dei massimi
artefici la civiltà di villa la
villeggiatura quanto fate la
villeggiatura
fate qualcosa di molto veneziano a
venezia si suppone siano stati inventati
gli occhiali e con certezza viene
inventato lo specchio nel 1540 è una
data spartiacque
prima di quel momento venivano
utilizzati dai metalli lucidati o dei
vetri grezzi che restituivano
un'immagine poco fedele da quel momento
in poi ognuno fu in grado di vedere se
stesso così come era e la percezione di
sé
cambiò radicalmente e per sempre quando
vi guardate allo specchio ogni mattina
che dio manda in terra e assonnati ri
mirate la vostra immagine in realtà
state ammirando una invenzione veneziana
venezia inventa un sistema elettorale lo
mette appunto film prima del mille lo
affina lo fa diventare pressoché
definitivo nel 1297 e quando due fra le
democrazie più antica della storia
moderna quella statunitense e quella
francese compiuta e le rispettive
rivoluzioni decidono di dotarsi di un
sistema elettorale dove credete che lo
vadano a pescare vengono a venezia e
studiano quello in uso da secoli ancora
oggi in francia è invalso l'uso del
ballottaggio nei paesi anglofoni
l'urna elettorale si chiama ballot boxx
entrambe retaggio dell'utilizzo di
ballotte pajot e con le quali i
veneziani e leggevano il doge e le altre
magistrature dello stato
potrei continuare narrando vedi come
venezia apra al mondo la prima casa da
gioco pubblica nel 1638 il ridotto
grande un anno prima aveva avuto luogo
una rappresentazione musicale in un
teatro al san cassiano alla quale era
stato ammesso per la prima volta nella
storia un pubblico pagante e questo
utilizzo del biglietto apparentemente
così semplice sconvolge invece per
sempre i canoni della composizione
invece mi limiterò a salutarvi con un
ciao un saluto semplice diretto bello e
ora mai usato in molti luoghi della
terra
ebbene e veneziano quando dite ciao
parlate con i veneziani di qualche
secolo fa ciao non è nient'altro che la
contrazione di schiava vostro forma
ossequiosa di saluto molto in voga ai
tempi della serenissima quando dite ciao
a qualcuno vi dichiarate suo schiavo
attenzione non è una forma di
sottomissione è un ossequio l'altra
persona anno vi sta costringendo a fare
nulla
siete voi che serenamente
vi mettete il suo servizio non c'è
violenza nel ciao
d'altronde venezia formalmente la prima
nazione al mondo che abolisce la
schiavitù in un documento ufficiale nel
960 avete sentito bene 960 l'ultima a
farlo fu la mauritania nel 1980 1020
anni più tardi
ciò non significa che i veneziani non
abbiano avuto degli schiavi o non ne
abbiano commerciati nel corso della
storia
i veneziani hanno anche una bellissima
bandiera che è fra le più antiche ancora
esistenti e tuttora in utilizzo ed è
anche l'unico vessillo di uno stato
nazionale sul quale compaia la parola
pace
anche questo è curioso per un popolo che
fu bravissimo a fare la guerra e che
inventò e montò per primo
ingegneristicamente i cannoni laterali
sulle sue navi
fa tutto parte dalle contraddizioni di
un grande popolo con una lunga storia ma
tutto si tiene pace schiavo vostro ciao
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]